give
your life to god
we are asking you to surrender
your extractive contracting
personhood identity
we're asking you to make a shift
to seeing yourself the way
that god sees you
as you know i came back from
bentino massaro's shift into permanent
alignment retreat in costa rica in march
and this map
paradigm
is very profound and has become
deeper in resonance with my heart
and with sharing with our audience
and it's quite a simple understanding
giving your life to god means shifting
away
from the extractive person
identity
you identifying yourself as
a person
trying to extract peace and happiness
through relationships and substances
and experiences and material possessions
also known as maya also known as the
illusion or the intoxication
is causing you suffering and it's
causing you to
inflict malevolence upon the creation
so the shift
to seeing yourself the way that god sees
you
has a lot to do with becoming
aware
of awareness becoming aware
of being becoming aware of
i am or i exist
it's seeing yourself the way god sees
you
is seeing yourself before
all of your identity so can you be
the pure subject without
your name and without your career
and without your religion without your
country
without all of the attributes
so strip away the identifiers
and the attributes the onion layers
until you get to just the pure subject
itself
the pure witness the pure observer the
pure
consciousness the pure empty bear
awareness beingness i am-ness
that is what is trying to come through
as you make this shift the
love light unity wisdom intelligence
channels through like clean pipes
like hollow bamboo
you become the i
you become the i itself
rather than being the person
the person tries to serve the person
extractively
the i
focuses on a calling a divine
transcendent north star noble aim
that is in service to the creation
rather than extraction
because the i sees everything as
god it sees everything as a divine
play the entire universe
becomes the body
so the shift in identity
giving your life to god is sacrificing
the conditioned contracted energy of
personhood
to shifting your identity to god
to the entire universe at play with
itself and
surrendering your life to a divine
north star calling a transcendent noble
aim
that is in service to the creation
awakening
that is what is meant by giving your
life
to god surrender
the identity of personhood
that is trying to extract peace and
happiness
from relationships substances
experiences material possessions
surrender the very contracted energy of
personhood
and the contracted identity of
personhood
with all of its onion layers
and shed those onion layers through this
shift inward
to become aware of the pure subject
itself the pure
seer the pure consciousness awareness
beingness
i am i exist that
is god that is the very capital i
the capital s self
shift to the calling work
the north star the noble aim that is
transcendent
and that is in service to the creation
awakening
become a steward become a shepherd for
the awakening
of the creation
give your life to god
that is what we ask of you
thank
and you you bentino thank you team
thank you anurag and richard
this whole idea of the shift into
permanent alignment
is so divine
and we're so grateful
thank you
you